AINSLEY: AS THE WHITE HOUSE
GRAPPLES WITH HOW TO DESCRIBE
THE MY GRANT SURGE AMERICANS
LIVING ALONG THE BORDER ARE
SOUNDING THE ALARM ON THIS
CRISIS.
OUR NEXT GUEST IS A RANCHER FROM
NEW MEXICO AND SAYS THAT THE
NUMBER OF MIGRANTS TRAVELING
THROUGH HER PROPERTY HAS
INCREASED DRASTICALLY.
OUR GUEST NAME IS AMANDA ADONI
AND SHE JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING, AMANDA.
>> GOOD MORNING, HOW ARE YOU?
AINSLEY: DOING WELL.
I KNOW YOU ARE WORRIED YOU HAVE
A FAMILY AND YOU THINK ABOUT
THAT AND YOU DON’T WANT ANYTHING
TO GO WRONG.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING ON A REGULAR
BASIS NOW?
>> UM, THE PRESENCE OF WALKERS
AND A LOT OF, A LOT OF BORDER
PATROL TRYING TO CATCH THEM.
AINSLEY: SO THEY JUST WALK
THROUGH YOUR PROPERTY?
HOW CLOSE DO THEY GET TO YOUR
HOUSE.
>> FAIRLY CLOSE.
A LOT OF THEM COME INTO THE
HOUSE.
AINSLEY: THEY COME INTO THE
HOUSE?
>> WELL, NOT IN TO MY HOUSE PER
SE BUT LIKE DOWN INTO THE YARD
ASKING FOR FOOD AND WATER.
AINSLEY: WOW, DO YOU HELP THEM?
WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> YEAH.
WE HAVE, YOU KNOW, WE DON’T WANT
TO GET HURT, SO WE FEED AND
WATER THEM AND TRY TO GET THEM
TO GO ON OR WE COME IN THE HOUSE
AND CALL THE BORDER PATROL.
AINSLEY: WHAT’S INTERESTING IS
IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS, THEY
HAVE RELEASED ALL THE NUMBERS OF
EVERY SINGLE SECTOR DOWN THERE
IN YOUR AREA, EL PASO.
YOU HAVE SEEN MORE THAN DOUBLE
INCREASE IN THE UNACCOMPANIED
ALIEN CHILDREN FROM THIS PAST
FEBRUARY TO FEBRUARY BEFORE.
LOOK AT THOSE NUMBERS.
MORE THAN 5,000 CAME IN THIS
PAST FEBRUARY.
WHEN IT COMES TO FAMILY UNITS,
IT’S ACTUALLY DOWN IN YOUR AREA,
8500 LAST FEBRUARY.
THIS PAST FEBRUARY ALMOST 6,000.
MOST OF THEM ARE ASPERGILLUS,
ACCORDING TO THOSE NUMBERS THE
RIO GRANDE AREA AND THEN SINGLE
ADULTS INCREASED FROM MORE THAN
12,000 LAST FEBRUARY TO 41,000.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA?
>> I THINK, IN PART, IT’S THE
ASYLUM COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT
THAT THEY TERMINATED.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION JUST
BASICALLY GAVE THEM A GREEN
LIGHT TO COME UP.
AND THEY ARE NOT WANTING TO GET
CAUGHT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO RUN AS FAST
AS THEY CAN.
AINSLEY: I KNOW YOU HAVE TOLD
OUR PRODUCERS THAT THEY AREN’T
AFRAID.
>> NO.
THEY ARE NOT AFRAID.
AINSLEY: WHEN THEY SEE A BORDER
AGENT.
WHEN THEY WOULD SEE A BORDER
AGENT WHEN TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT,
WHAT WOULD THEY DO COMPARED TO
WHAT THEY DO NOW?
>> WHEN THEY SAW A BORDER AGENT
BEFORE, THEY STOPPED AND THEY
WAITED.
AND NOW THEY KEEP TRYING TO GO.
AINSLEY: AND DO THE BORDER
AGENTS LET THEM GO?
>> NO, NO.
THEY CATCH THEM.
WHEN THEY SEE THEM.
THAT’S THE BIG PROBLEM IS WHEN
THEY GET UP TO MY HOUSE,
ESSENTIALLY THEY ARE ALMOST --
AINSLEY: THEY ARE ON AMERICAN
SOIL AND SO THEY ARE ALLOWED TO
STAY UNDER THIS ADMINISTRATION.
LAST QUESTION, WHAT’S YOUR
BIGGEST CONCERN HERE?
>> NOW THAT THE BORDER POLICY
HAS CHANGED, WHAT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN NOW?
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO WITH
STOPPING ASYLUM SEEKERS?
I JUST FEEL SAD FOR THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE TRYING TO COME IN
LEGALLY AND THEY CAN’T BECAUSE
OF ALL THESE ASYLUM SEEKERS.
AINSLEY: THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR